echi is a pretty niche word
something that even many beginning anime
watchers don't know the meaning of
but to anyone who spent their fair share
of time watching anime it's
understandably a staple of the community
itself
body pillows those weird mouse pads with
big ol honkers for
quote-unquote ergonomics fan arts
arguably
none of this would really exist without
the idea of ecchi in the first place
and though it's often thought of as the
darker side of anime the side that
casual or people who simply oppose the
idea are hesitant to indulge in
in my eyes it has shaped an entire
generation of anime watchers in one way
or another
if you enjoyed them or not joking about
high school dxd or high school of the
dead is commonplace among weeaboos
for lack of a better word but in recent
years i personally feel like its effect
has waned
the impact that those aforementioned
shows had is permanent on the anime
community
but thinking on recent anime inner
species reviewers redo of healer
none of them really hold a candle to
that level of infamy
so why is this the case is ecchi anime
simply getting worse becoming
overshadowed by their older predecessors
i would argue that this is far from the
case but more so
it reflects the aging of the younger
generation that was encaptured by the
beauty of the first great wave of edgy
anime
if i may call it that and as anime gets
saturated with more shows
more ditchy the power of each individual
show falters
and falls flat compared to not just
older shows
but the other rapidly growing genres
that pop more to audiences
let's explore the gradual but evident
demise of
ecchi anime let's have a very serious
talk about the least
serious genre in anime and if i somehow
offend you say an opinion that
contradicts yours throughout this video
i just want to clarify that these are
just my opinions on how the anime
community has changed over the past
decade
and how that has been reflected in the
echi genre
if you've got this far into the video
without knowing what echi really is
it's a subgenre of anime and manga
defined by light and
often playful sexual themes and imagery
and i would argue that
all of the most well-known and more
notably influential
etchy anime came out before 2015
and while this certainly might not seem
like a long time ago
six years is a long time especially
considering that
dozens if not hundreds of new anime are
produced every year
high school of the dead high school dxd
seikan no kwasser tolavru
even if you were to go to more modern
edgy shows like no game no life
seven deadly sins kill la kill all of
these came out before
2015. but i think something to note
about these shows the seven deadly sins
and no game no life
the ones that are most popular but still
fit into the etching genre
is that they aren't really known for
echi specifically
seven deadly sins is a long-running
shonen killakil is action and power-ups
no game no life is
games and i know this is generalizing
them and subjective but compare it back
to the old shows
do you think of anything in high school
of the dead in seika no quasar
accepts the echi and i think this brings
up a very big factor
to echi anime's decline how the very
rapid growth of anime in the 2010s
led to the need for anime to feel more
complex than just etchy to compete
to remain notable and make a name for
the show
when i first began watching anime maybe
in 2012 give or take
anime wasn't necessarily small at that
point far from it
actually but it was inarguably far more
niche than it is now
and back then for many people netflix
was the gateway
myself included death note full metal
alchemist brotherhood
these are big not just because they're
good shows but
because of netflix and a large part of
our generation
or to be more specific the generation
that grew up with anime
were introduced to it when naruto was
airing or bleach
that generation scored through netflix
for new shows because
as kids it was the easiest way it's what
we knew best
we weren't pirating at that point we
weren't really using crunchyroll
and this inevitably led to the discovery
of ancient classics nowadays
like freezing and heaven's lost property
and it was
weird it was new to see anime that were
so forward in sexual content and
suggestions as a kid
on a generally family-friendly platform
like netflix
and though i'm probably understating the
amount of anime on netflix at the time
or was widely available it still wasn't
massive
and i think this made it easier to be
exposed to etchy anime shows that
weren't adhering to mainstream appeal
there were less shows to wade through to
get through that really deep cut stuff
i mean all the old classic etchy anime
that i can think of
follow a pretty similar formula a harem
big breasts and some kind of fantasy
action plot that makes the dude at the
center of the harem really important
and while some of this simplicity
repetitive nature can be attributed to
the simplicity of the genre it's
also because anime wasn't as developed
then as it is now
perhaps developed isn't the right word
because a bunch of classics
great really deep anime came out at the
time but now that anime has gotten
so much bigger and so much more
competitive to make a name for a show
having ecchi alone just won't do having
the same copy and paste main character
only really changing up the girls won't
do
again bringing up seven deadly sins no
game no life and kill akhil
the three most popular etchy anime
according to my anime list
these reflect the turning points the
period between late 2013 and 2014 when
shows like attack on titan and tokyo
ghoul drove anime to far
larger audiences it's a hot topic to all
those edgy stores
in the local mall and so in a way this
over saturation of anime the growing fan
base
as a result has locked the origins the
heavens lost property the freezing
the roots of etching anime into the
recesses
of what is now an older generation's
memories nothing but nostalgia
but i don't think that's all there is to
it it's also simply the effect of time
itself what is timeless to older
generations becomes
relics for the new one and in anime a
community that is constantly shifting
with each season
somehow my favorites like steins gate
and mushishi are
now old shows which is crazy to believe
it's insane
but it's true for anyone who's been
watching anime for a long time
tokyo ghoul is old fulmanna lochmas
brotherhood was well
over a decade ago naruto shippuden
finished airing like
four years ago but huge shows like the
ones i just listed
everyone still knows old fans and new
but classics like high school dxd and to
love roo
are being forgotten and because they
don't stand the test of time
again it encourages studios it
encourages mangakas and creators
all across japan to ditch the idea of
simple echi of just that
and have it more as an extra trait in an
anime that focuses primarily on
something else
which isn't necessarily bad but it's
diluting ecchi into a side genre
something that really can't stand on its
own
and so as the older generation moves on
so does anime
it matures it leaves behind the niche
but classic takes on echi for more
complex
and standout ideas which is honestly for
the better
i think that throughout the video it
might have seemed like i think
it's bad that anime is moving on from
this which isn't really the case
but it's always sad to see a piece of
your childhood a classic regardless of
whether it was really good or not being
forgotten
so to answer the questions i posed
earlier in the video
i in all honesty don't think there will
be another etching anime to reach that
level
the level that high school of the dead
high school dxd
in total of rue are not only prominent
members in but help
to actually make themselves and this
level isn't really based on how good the
show is
i argue that inner species reviewer
which came out a year or so ago
is not only more tasteful but funnier
and simply better entertainment than
most
if not all old ecchi shows but its
impact
is what i'm looking at and it's hard for
any anime to make that kind of impacts
nowadays more so than ever
just because there are so many animates
go up against
but even more for etchy simply because
of well
frankly how poor the genre ages and
because of how easily recreatable it is
i think the demise of ecchi was
inevitable
of course its effects will always remain
but what i'm talking about is the
classic
the origins of it itself what it will
become in the future will i'm sure be
far
from what it used to be which again i
don't think is very bad
but it's certainly a change and it's
something that we have to acknowledge
anyway that was my really long-winded
way of analyzing not just the genre of
echi but how the entire 2010s have
changed anime into what it is now
i'll be in my closet crying as i cuddled
my body pillow of riousgramery
if you don't know who she is then
man that's just further proof of my
point
as always this has been the anime
culture corner i hope you enjoyed the
video
leave a comment on what you think don't
forget to like and subscribe for
future in-depth show manga and character
analyses
you